How are.
How are my moms doing? My mom friends,
the ones home with kids all summer,
right, right, right.
I'm losing my fucking mind.
I was not made for this.
And then I am babysitting another child for the summer.
So on top of my four,
I get to hear another one talk about how bored he is.
At least that one doesn't talk shit to me,
cause he's not mine, but mine sure do.
So I'm literally, like,
snuck out in the backyard and I'm just
waiting for the next request.
Um, so, yeah,
I really think I get, like,
the summer blues just from this.
It's like, I don't know.
I would love if my kids were at some camp.
I would love if we had activities and vacations and shit,
but we don't. So we're fucking home,
and that's fucking great.